you're
you're reminding us that uh there's
there's uh two biological systems on
both ends of that communication
and the one the easier i guess maybe
half
as difficult a thing to do and the hope
with neural link is that
we can communicate with an ai system so
yeah where one side of that is a little
bit more controllable
but but even just that is exceptionally
difficult
let's talk about two two neuronal
systems talking to each other suppose
that gpt4
tells gpd3 hey give me all your
knowledge right
it's ready that's hilarious i have ten
times more hardware i'm ready just feed
me
what's gpt3 going to do is it going to
say oh here's my
10 billion parameters no no way
the simplest way and perhaps the fastest
way for gp3 to transfer all this
knowledge to its older body that has a
lot more hardware
is to regenerate every single possible
human sentence that it can possibly
yes create keep talking keep talking and
just re-encode it all together
so maybe what language does is exactly
that it's taking one
generative cognitive model it's running
it forward to emit
utterances that kind of makes sense in
my cognitive frame and it's re-encoding
them into yours
through the parsing of that same
language and i think the conversation
might
might
actually be the most efficient way to do
it so not just talking
but uh interactive so talking back and
forth yeah asking questions
interrupting so gpd304 will constantly
be interrupted
just annoying and annoying and
annoyingly
yeah but but the beauty of that is also
that
as we're interrupting each other there's
all kinds of misinterpretations
that happen that you know as basically
when my students speak
i will often know that i'm
misunderstanding what they're saying
and i'll be like hold that thought for a
second let me tell you what i think i
understood which i know is different
what you said then i'll say that and
then someone else
in the same zoom meeting will basically
say well
you know here's another way to think
about what you just said and then by the
third iteration
we're somewhere completely different
that if we could actually communicate
with full you know neural network
parameters back and forth of that
knowledge
and idea and coding would be
far inferior because they're re-encoding
with our own as we said last time
emotional baggage and cognitive baggage
from our unique experiences
through our shared experiences
distinct encodings in the context of all
our unique
experiences is leading to so much
more diversity
of perspectives and again going back to
this whole concept of this
entire network of all of human cognitive
systems connected to each other
and sort of how ideas and memes permeate
through that
that's sort of what really creates a
whole new level
of human experience through
this reasoning layer and this
computational layer
that obviously lives on top of our
cognitive layer
you